ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك
سياده اللواء اذا كل هذا الحديث عن باخمت
ومحاولات من البعض لتقليل اهميتها هذا
الدفاع والهجوم المستميت من الطرفين كيف
يمكن وصف الحاله الان في ضخمه
قلت قبل تقريبا ثمين ساعه ان المعركه
الحاسمه
الحقيقي لم تبدا لانه يجب ان تكون غرب
النهر لانه 60% من المدينه يقع الى الغرب
من النهر ولا تزال هناك طريق رئيسي وطرق
عبر الضواحي تصل من خلال الامدادات
والان كلا الجيشين في هذه المعركه تحديدا
يتبنى العقيد القتاليه
السوفييتيه الجانب الروسي
ينفذ هجمات متلاحقه من موجات بشريه ومعدات
لان القاعده الاساسيه في هذه العقيده تقول
يجب تحقيق الهدف دون النظر الى الكلفه
في الجانب الاوكراني عاد لتبني هذه
النظريه يجب التمسك بهذه الارض مهما كان
الثمن وبالتالي القتال سيكون اكثر شراسه
اكثر دمويه لكن في المقاربه العسكريه
الاجماليه اذا لم يتم ارسال قوات رئيسيه
حقيقيه وليس امدادات فاخبط ستسقط ولكن
ستكون فاتوره التكاليف باهظه جدا للجانب
الروسي وباهض بدرجه اقل للجانب الاوكراني
اذا الكلى الجانبين عاد الى تبني العقيده
السوفيتيه ضروره تحقيق الهدف بغض النظر عن
التكلفه هل هذه التكلفه او الثمن الباهض
يعني يستحق او تستحق ما ما يبذل من اجلها
وانا اسال عن الجانبين الاوكراني والروسي
يا سيدي يعني بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني
منذ منذ تقريبا عده اسابيع منذ شهرين بدات
بدايه او بذور الخلاف حول اداره المعركه
قال العقيد القتالي الغربيه عندما تضع
هدفا يجب تحقيقه تنظر الى فاتوره التكاليف
وكانت النصائح الغربيه وكل من يتبنى الفكر
العسكري الغربي كان يرى ان من الافضل
للقوات الاوكرانيه ان تنسحب قبل عده
اسابيع توفر الجهد توفر الوقت توظف القوات
في اطر جديده منها ما يبني انظمه وخطوط
دفاعيه
امامسك واكراماتوريست ومنها ما يمكن
توظيفه اما باتجاه الايمان شمالا او
باتجاه جنوبا من اجل تحقيق انجازات وهذا
ما تحدث به المستشارين الامريكيين لكن
الجان ب الاوكراني يعتبر ان سقوط باخمت من
ناحيه نفسيه على الجيش الاوكراني بصوره
سلبيه
والسيطره عليها روسيا البعد النفسي اعتبر
مهم للغايه واصبح يعلو على فاتوره
التكاليف وهذا هو الفرق بين اداره المعركه
من خلال العقائد القتاليه الغربيه
والعقيده السوفيتي
شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان لو فايزه الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي